a hearing today could determine if las
vegas metro police officers will face
charges
for a deadly shooting last year
25-year-old jorge gomez was shot by
officers on june 1st
outside the federal courthouse downtown
it was a
tense night with a black lives matter
protest ending and metro police officer
shaymi colonize was shot and wounded
just a few miles away
in a separate incident hector mejia is
now live at the clark county government
center where supporters of gomez and his
family are expected to rally a bit later
this morning hi hector
[Applause]
hey there alex good morning to you and
we've learned that seven local
organizations including aclu nevada are
gathering out here this morning and
earlier this week i had a chance to talk
with the family attorney who told me
the gomez family is not doing well right
now they do not believe the police
shooting of gomez
of jorge gomez was justified
every day is a battle for for for the
gomez family
they lost their brother they lost their
son
and and this is not a son or a brother
that
was distant was a bad person that
was heartless or lacked empathy this was
a caring son
the intention of a public fact-finding
review is to provide transparency about
an officer's deadly use of force
it begins at eight this morning inside
clark county commission chambers
the da's office typically brings in
witnesses and makes a presentation about
their version of the facts
family attorneys say surveillance video
contradicts metro police and shows jorge
gomez was running away
and not pointing his gun at officers
when he was shot 19 times
and killed in june of last year
i'm very curious to know
how are they going to justify this i
want to hear it we haven't gotten any
definitive answers like i get it yeah
he showed up to a rally with guns but
that's illegal
people show up to costco with guns
people show up to grocery stores across
our state with guns
they're not getting shot and killed
the family has filed a federal civil
rights lawsuit that was back in august
naming at least four metro officers and
we're told that lawsuit is still in the
process of gathering evidence
as it moves forward through the courts
and it's also important to remember that
there will be no formal decision of any
kind after the review
people are still gathering out here
though and the family attorney has a
message for supporters we'll have that
part of the story
still ahead in the next half hour
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now